we're told the graph of y is equal to
square root of x is shown below fair
enough which of the following is the
graph of y is equal to 2 times the
square root of negative x
minus 1 and they give us some choices
here and so i encourage you to pause
this video and try to figure out on your
own before we work through this together
all right now let's work through this
together and the way that i'm going to
do it is i'm actually going to try to
draw what the graph of 2 times the
square root of negative x minus 1 should
look like and then i'll just look at
which of the choices is closest to what
i drew and the way that i'm going to do
that is i'm going to do it step by step
so we already see what y
equals the square root of x looks like
but let's say we just want to build up
so let's say we want to now figure out
what is the graph of y is equal to the
square root of instead of an x under the
radical sign let me put a negative x
under the under the radical sign what
would that do to it
well whatever was happening at a certain
value of x will now happen at the
negative of that value of x so square
root of x is not defined for negative
numbers now this one won't be defined
for positive numbers
and the behavior that you saw at x
equals 2 you would now see at x equals
negative two the behavior that you saw
at x equals four you will now see at x
equals negative four and so on and so
forth so
the y equals the square root of negative
x is going to look some is going to look
like this you've essentially flipped it
over the y
we have flipped it over the y axis
all right so we've done this part
now let's scale that now let's multiply
that by 2.
so what would y is equal to 2 times the
square root of negative x look like
well it would look like this red curve
but at any given x value we're going to
get twice as high so at x equals
negative 4 instead of getting to 2 we're
now going to get to four at x equals
negative nine instead of getting to
three we're now going to get to six
now at x equals zero we're still going
to be at zero because two times zero is
zero so it's going to look it's going to
look like that something like that so
that's y equals 2 times the square root
of negative x and then last but not
least
what will
y let me do that in a different color
what will
y equals 2 times the square root of
negative x minus 1 look like
well whatever y value we were getting
before we're now just going to shift
everything down by 1. so if we were at 6
before we're going to be at 5 now if we
were at
if we were at 4 before we're now going
to be at 3
if we were at 0 before we're now going
to be at negative 1. and so our curve is
going to look
something
like
something like that so let's look for
let's see which choices
match that so let me scroll down here
and
both c and d kind of look right but
notice right at zero we wanted to be at
negative one so
d is exactly what we had drawn that at
nine we're at five at we're at negative
nine we're at five at negative four
we're at three and at zero we're at
negative one exactly what we had drawn
let's do another example
so here this is a
similar question
now they graphed the cube root of x y is
equal to the cube root of x and then
they say which of the following is the
graph of this business and they give us
choices again
so once again pause this video and try
to work it out on your own before we do
this together
all right now let's work on this
together and i'm going to do the same
technique i'm just going to build it up
piece by piece
so
this is already
y is equal to the cube root of x
so now let's build up on that let's say
we want to now have an x plus 2
under the radical sign
so let's graph y is equal to the cube
root of x plus 2.
well what this does is it shifts the
curve to
to the left and we've gone over this in
multiple videos before
so we are now here and you can even try
some values out to verify that at
at x equals zero
at x equals zero or actually let me put
it this way at x equals negative two
you're going to take the cube the cube
root of zero which is right over there
so we hit shift it we have now shifted
two to the left
to look something
to look something like
this
and now
let's build up on that
let's multiply this times a negative so
y is equal to the negative of the cube
root of x plus 2. what would that look
like
well if you multiply your whole
expression or the whole in this case the
whole
graph or the whole function by a
negative you're going to flip it over
the
horizontal axis and so it is now going
to look like this whatever y value
you're going to get before for a given x
you're now getting the opposite the
negative of it
so it's going to look
it's going to look
like that something like that so that is
y equal to the negative of the cube root
of x plus 2
and then
last but not least
we
are going to think about and i'm
searching for an appropriate color i
haven't used orange yet y is equal to
the negative of the cube root of x plus
2 and i'm going to add 5. so all that's
going to do is take this last graph and
shift it up by 5 whatever y value is
going to get before i'm now going to get
5 higher
so 5 higher let's see i was at 0 here so
now i'm going to be at
5 here so it's going to look it's going
to look something
something like
something
like
that i know i'm not drawing it perfectly
but you get the general the general idea
now let's look at the choices and i
think the key point to look at is this
point right over here that in our
original graph was at 0 0 now it is
going to be at negative 2 comma
5. so let's
look for it and it also should be
flipped so on the left hand side we have
the top part and on the right hand side
we have the the part that goes lower
so let's see
so
a c and b all have the left hand side as
the higher part and then the right hand
side being the lower part but we wanted
this point to be at negative 2 comma 5.
a doesn't have it there
b doesn't have it there
d we already said goes in the wrong
direction it's it's it's increasing
so let's see negative two comma five
it's indeed what we expected this is
pretty close to what we had drawn on our
own so choice c